hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alba
I'm John Humphrey we're going to watch
deep fake Roundtable Cruz Downey jr.
Lucas and more the streaming wars above
the line wow it's a title Collider
videos forget movie tuck forget Collider
live it's all about your new deep fakes
is what you guys are doing that soaring
heights these days this is a top award
video request for a man named Lance II
Dory I'm excited to check this out I
love their George Lucas one they've done
oh it's a parody of like the Round
Table's I actually watch those real
roundtables those are hilarious
Marquette has a hilarious new stand-up
you guys should check it out verse Asian
with some of Hollywood's most
recognizable faces I'm Mark Ellis and
I'm delighted to be joined today by Tom
Cruise I don't privilege to be here
[Music]
Downey jr. hi I'm Robert Downey jr. and
to his left is George well I apologize
earlier I had a burrito and I think I've
got the Kessel run gentlemen the world's
gone their heads like realize it's
streaming was dominating your industry
you know first I thought I was in other
word for golden showers turn out to be
what it is which is strange and also
perplexing and weird the fact that
something's come into your house into
your TV show it's invasive it's invasive
surgery there's a lot of different fine
print is in the whole the timeshare here
that's that's how it starts at first
everyone's running and rent streaming
yeah
Jurassic Park Jurassic Park when it came
out Jeff I don't know that you could
have been aware that eventually Jurassic
Park would be to send you DVDs Jeff you
remember the last DVD the Netflix sent
you oh gosh yes yes Metro Metro with
Eddie Murphy but I had a dinner party
and I remember that I was out of
coasters so I cleverly got the DVDs and
I use them as clusters and I never
returned them so never return your DVDs
Tom do you have any unclaimed DVDs that
you need to send back in that book well
actually my loyalty resides with
blockbuster I'm a blockbuster boy
ultimately it's physical disks in the
mail so I would things I did still do
that was they took all the the original
versions of Star Wars that these to rank
tonight when I kept them all so they
don't exist they're not circulation
anymore with these new streaming
services like there's news to us well
here you're going to have your own
obi-wan Kenobi show on the new service
yeah they finally figured it out
the crack that they were making all
these other ones and then the right
that's right hi George we're boring you
as pioneers and furthering the art of
cinema your take on streams well I've
said before the you know digital was the
future and now I get this [ __ ] sorry
you know I really can't believe you sold
out and you're doing this forces a [ __ ]
remember when JJ was going around
shilling for the force awakens and they
were just so oh yes what everybody were
shaking her 35-millimeter role you know
like like like Joe average in the Middle
States gives a [ __ ] doesn't care what's
a seat of thanks
fascinating to see this type of talk on
Star Wars Roberts Jim
thumpers us in Lucas over Hilton you got
to see Star Wars in theatres it was one
of those things where you remember where
you were at the time I remember because
I was peeing my parents child thanks a
lot ultimately Star Wars is the diuretic
if you certainly have a wild wacky world
that is all your own you actually have a
show on Disney plus the world according
to Jeff Goldblum well I don't want to
boast but yes yes we have two shows on
Disney plus they were sort of toeing the
company line of course you it Robert
have all the marvelous films now does he
plus we're all on does he Pleasant
Disney family except for I do understand
to the orbiting the Iron Man character a
lot of people were saying could be
nominated for an award that maybe you'd
be at the Academy Awards ceremony well
of course I would be deserving show I
think on some level because you know
I've given it my all you know I'm a team
player you know a nice guy you know I
smell good laughing what is it what is
it what is this pocket for breeze oh
this is I have to get this this is very
good yes if I can bring it back to the
to streaming conversation I'm sure
and the conversation about awards
there's a lot of debate in your
community right now about whether
streaming films should be considered for
Award nomination anything wins these
days anything can win at any time so
it's like you know if it's a Velveeta
commercial you know look out well
that's not gonna be considered for
motion pictures gunwale could she's done
black and white done perhaps French noir
sure sure like I said I think says Steve
Spielberg God I think he what he
disagrees I think he feels that of
course that this dreamy eligible for the
awards missus well I know Steven
Spielberg a good friend of George's he
does opinions on the state of affairs as
Martin Scorsese Robert he actually came
out recently in study he does not
consider Marvel Cinematic Universe films
to be cinema he compared them more
accurately to theme parks well these
guys are getting up their age twice and
they're having digestive problems so I
would I would just tribute yeah well
it's true to be done I have one if you'd
like to see it later it's it's keep them
because you never know you know keeps my
friends sure because I'm great I think
you're taking a diagram diagram
you're such an eccentric personality and
we see the current culture that's in
Hollywood
how have you avoided scandal I well well
I died I stayed I'd have gone a lot
mainly play my music jazz I'm doing a
lot of piano playing and years ago I was
sleeping with Davis Gina Davis by the
way oh well we don't need all the dirty
deeds I was hanging from the rafters has
to fly and we locked eyes and she's in
the insects that turns out to enjoy
oh it's Marvel oh yeah well as we get
back into the would be streaming service
Jordan would be what was your most
intense show binging experience Netflix
Hulu Amazon program really enjoying the
[Music]
understanding what's happening okay I'm
gonna give you the time for the question
you know the ice planet of Hoth was
based on this know where the idea came
from what I was eating flamin hot
cheetos and I was dreaming and they came
up with the idea for most of for the
lava planet so a lot of it's about
dreaming and eating robert there seems a
kate we're on a closer I got a camera
coming at me right now I'm Iron Man and
you are almost almost it was rumored and
we've heard sense that you were
considered for the role what happened we
do you know just some creative
differences and I was reading other
scripts it might be with something yeah
build out my own universitary the dark
universe does that work this
conversation back to above the line
territory let's do some fun rapid-fire
questions
George start with you if you could
Netflix and chill with anyone throughout
history so you would actually watch
Netflix we watch the film what's your
favorite what tiser kind of words with
friends
[Music]
I would have to see there's pigs and
birds
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
keep going ask me questions right stick
or otherwise you're gonna bust another
Robert if you could steal an Oscar from
anyone in Hollywood who would it be
oh that little girlfriend piano did she
win I take from her Anna Paquin I agree
she was I don't know if I'd steal it but
I would maybe ask for it from from a
McGinnis he's a big hero so I think it'd
be kind of fun you know what game right
he also played obi-wan Kenobi in kind of
a thing there yeah I'll just do it not
give it back there's just kidding of it
I'd be good George Lucas if you get
steal an Oscar I think I'd like to steal
an Oscar from anybody at this point I
hate to move it to this next topic
Robert starting with you porn mobile or
laptop depends if I'm on my back or my
top that's a sizeable take that you try
that's all I own and then you know
obviously I say dirty things like you
know is the
[Music]
thank you for um you prefer it mobile or
on your well you know I gotta say
neither because I did it imagination you
could use your mind that's it
tantric but sometimes I like to do it
while I'm jogging strapped to my belly
and of course I look down sure because
because the cardiovascular we should go
jogging me haven't loved to or did you
wear this come on
yes Walhalla great very price that's how
I like it though jobina Tom Cruise are
gonna go jogging fully clothed the
canyons is a selling point right yes yes
I think that's gonna do it for us here
[Music]
Robert Downey jr. and Ewan McGregor
thank you so much for tuning in today
and we'll see you real soon on another
above the leg
memorable intimate conversations with
some of Hollywood's most recognizable
face
nice town curse your favorite week hello
I'm good Wow Wow so that looks so real
engine video thanks for watching fly
today there is no substitute button if
you want to see more things like this be
sure to hit that subscribe this is
obi-wan kenobi subscribe and a little
better to subscribe to click the bill
and ok bye bye oh man that deep fake I'm
Mark Ellis look great Christian doesn't
mark impression that's pretty great ah
you broke the internet yeah bet there's
not one comment not one that says that
dude shut down the internet the jokes
are done we did it oh we did it
it was fun one yeah I was able to just
get lost in it I would stop thinking
about the deep face of the first some of
them have is like uncanny look to them
other times you could see like the
grease yeah especially in certain
movements so when you get lost in it
then you just start to take it as like
the weird bit it is this must have been
improvised in the beginning if I like
they were trying to out improv each
other I thought these guys were awesome
they all had such great fine-tuned
detail characters of who their
personalities were they were embody I
really thought the Tom Cruise won and
George Lucas one felt the most like
people the Jeff Goldblum one felt like
it's a great impersonation and it's it's
great mimicry it sounded a lot like him
as it everyone else is but it was Tom
Cruise it just felt like they seemed
like three-dimensional humans like that
the exact responses they would give for
things were so on point with what seeing
them in interviews and stuff absolutely
adored it who was your favorite George
Lucas has become
a favor to mine just because I really
love this take on him and it does feel
sort of uncanny in a way I love just how
much he doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anything for coming off that Star Star
Wars rise of Skywalker like trailer
reaction and then this like whoever's
doing that impression just has this
effortless yeah I don't care attitude
that really tickles me even McGregor got
me in this one just because he seemed
like he was the kid at the adults table
and he was the most understated
impression which at a table full of
people competing with their impressions
actually does start to stand out and
shine a little bit ah it's so weird Oh
China zerud sir joke you guys know
movies
Oh shine sir oh the doctor sleep cuz cuz
shine hahahahahaha it's good I didn't
even pull that one together it's like
the apps joke in the middle of with
Robert Downey and the mozzarella sticks
yes til them kids and yeah Jeff go boom
it was like a Jeff Goldblum solo I just
started the Disney Plus show the Jeff
Goldblum one that it was pretty accurate
it see the thing is these are all better
than whatever the hell I could possibly
do with any of these impressions alright
so automatically they're all incredible
there's some that felt like you were
doing impressions and there were other
ones that felt like characters the you
McGregor one was the one that I thought
was the most lackluster I get where
you're coming from and like that does
make sense being the kid the table all
the adults and having this sort of sense
of wonder and I think that impersonation
that element of it is really nailed down
let me have like one moment that I
actually thought was like funny yeah I
just enjoyed the impression I guess he
wasn't the funniest by any stretch
because he seemed to have liked the
least riffing and the least jokes and
the least feature in this and that's
gonna happen cuz you can't have
everybody be status one well his
personality I don't think quite fits
even if these were all the real actors I
don't feel like his personality quite is
on the same level more of a caricature
with everyone else even McGregor I take
a little bit more of a serious actor
level it's not to say I don't like Tom
Cruise is one of my favorite actors ever
all of them are but their personalities
even McGregor personality isn't as well
known
or define in the public eye as well as
everyone else's that you see in this
video you know like we all know who
Tillich that intense charisma of Tom
Cruise we all know that cynicism of
George Lucas we all know that narcissism
of Robert Downey jr. and we all know the
weird zany quirkiness of Jeff Goldblum
that they all really brought that to
life and I thought Mark Ellis did a
really great job on handling this fun
little improv game they had going here
he's the anchor
yeah like the right reaction I imagine
this possum outtakes there was a point
towards the end where it seemed like he
was ready to cut really an hour of
footage for this I love to see it
extended cut of this cuz as it kept
going I just I didn't want it to stop
when they said they're editing and I'm
like oh I go watch this forever nah dude
feature-length film we're talking it
starts in the studio but then it goes
off road then you get so many more
cameos endless cameos and then throw in
a couple actual cameos to really confuse
people and you get an above the line
movie kickstart it that'd be great kudos
to the editor here because this is a lot
of hard sound design to work around you
kind of hear it the room tone cuts out
yeah and that's when you're focusing on
one actor and you moved to another one
in a different shot really noticeable
cut in the audio I couldn't tell if that
was a was like an edge or if that was
like a nod to how a lot of these
roundtable like you're dealing with a
lot of lav mics or something was it like
an intentional thing maybe but when you
get an improv like this you have to you
need a really good editor and no one to
cut to because some of these are not
funny on its own like you were just
watching it in like one master shot
depending on like the certain cuts that
you would make or reactions by somebody
else yeah that's what makes it really
work as a fan of like the Hollywood
Round Table's this was a very big
delight for myself oh yeah enjoy these
while they last before--the deep fake
technology becomes a real issue
well there's a good there's a channel
called control a control shift base who
does these amazing deep fakes but it
seems like it's become a technology that
people are slowly but surely mastering
over time there are concerns about these
sinister implications the deep icy
technology at deep fake James Dean let's
do this fake everything all right guys
well thank you so much for being here
make sure to subscribe to Collider video
you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click our notification about the
get notified whenever we got a YouTube
video ok check us on patreon where we
got a bunch of goodies Lance door he is
engaged and he is gonna be getting
married in Hawaii baby so excited for
you dude that is such a romantic spot to
get married what I would really
recommend is you get the will taken care
of as soon as possible because it's easy
to get rid of your new wife on your
honeymoon in Hawaii though were in the
ocean and then collect whatever life
insurance you can get off of her use
that money to increase your pledge on
patreon
everybody wins dude so take it from me
man if you want to know the best way to
kill your wife it's in Hawaii master the
deep fake and if anybody asks you can
just send them videos of her hanging out
in Hawaii perf we all know you're really
gay land so cut it out
you